autre tradition du 14-juillet
l'interview télévisée du président de la
république jacques chirac s'est exprimé
sur les principaux dossiers du moment
il a déclaré que la cohabitation avec le
premier ministre était conforme au
souhait des français ce qui ne l'a pas
empêché d'être critique à l'égard du
gouvernement il a souligné le sentiment
d'insécurité des français et la
stagnation de leur pouvoir d'achat
nous écoutons le président de la
république nous sommes dans une période
de croissance forte et le pouvoir
d'achat n'augmente pas ce qu'on a trop
de réglementation que des exemples des
35 heures je suis favorable à la
diminution du temps de travail et mais
que je pensais que c'était là aussi dans
le cadre de cette démocratie sociale que
j'appelle de mes voeux des décisions qui
devaient être pris entre les partenaires
sociaux et non pas réglementé pour tout
le monde et de la même façon à partir
d'un d'une décision législative ou
réglementaire mais cela crée des
comportements dans les entreprises qui
consiste à bloquer les salaires
est ce que c'est un grand progrès peut
interroger
c'est pour ça que je vous dis le
dialogue est plus porteur de progrès
social
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui c'était pas
vrai elle dix ans il ya vingt ans que la
réglementation a délinquance s'installe
l'insécurité s'installe se banalise
et quand vous écoutez les français et 10
ha il ya c'est la puissance des pouvoirs
publics c'est l'impunité pour les
délinquants
je pense que une partie de ce problème
devrait être pour être mieux réglée
assumé par les maires je crois je parle
de la police de proximité pourquoi parce
que le maire c'est en quelque sorte un
médecin généraliste et avant de faire
appel à des spécialistes il faut d'abord
laisser le généraliste faire son
diagnostic et apporter son entraînement
on aurait tout à y gagner